[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de paf
nous allons aborder évidemment
l'actualité l'actualité chargée de la
semaine on voit parler évidemment de la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites on va parler de la france à ce
qu'elle va bien ou pas si bien que ça on
va parler de démocratie
et puis aussi de cette affaire étrange
de la ferme il a vous savez cette jeune
femme qui a qui a été menacé sur les
réseaux sociaux parce que elle avait
critiqué les religions notamment l'islam
et pour en parler
jean baptiste du clerck bonjour bonjour
madrid très bien merci toujours maîtres
de cours des deux jours de vite me sens
très bien à l'université de verser 50
spécialistes de la pêche sur les
selistes châteauneuf du pape spécial
autre que le droit d'y figurer
merci ne présenter que stéphane xo qui
prend ce wind aussi très ouvert à
beaucoup d'autres à beaucoup d'autres
voudront la marche à pied la marche à
pied oui oui le vélo plus que le
véhicule terrestre à moteur la musique
large en fait oui parce que la notion
difficile oui il m'arrive de d2
descendre en bas et de monter ou
jean-michel pléonasme seraient légères
charles lajoie dit bonjour vous allez
vous fort bien fort bien et vous devez
noter qu' il n'y a pas de présence
féminine dans sa division ya pas de vent
réussi à exclure
enfin enfin seul enfin entre nous non
malheureusement
les rays ont mon livre bienne ne sais
quel esprit d'à propos
d'abord la mer
marenostrum alors c'est notre mère à
tous notre mère à tous et là c'est une
magnifique rivière d'eau une ode à la
méditerranée justement et c'est une
histoire ce n'est pas un roman policier
cinq hommes normand pas policier mais
presque c'est une très belle histoire
d'une bande de gamins qui se promène sur
les rives de la méditerranée y en a un
qui disparaît en mer etc sur un radeau
et puis voilà et c'est de cette
disparition tragique n'est toute une
histoire autour de la méditerranée
jusque 40 ans plus tard raison le var
ah oui vraiment on est en aidant on est
dans le dans le var d'entendre des
calanques magnifique et c'est vraiment
un truc magnifique sur la mer sur cette
région qui est qui et superbe qui est
hélas maintenant la mer la plus polluées
du monde ou presque mais mais qui reste
quand même un endroit tellement beau
tellement magnifique et l'hiver nous a
une plume absolument superbe et on est
vraiment très très content d'avoir
publié ce livre et je parle sous le
contrôle de deux de stéphane marsaudon
si on aime la méditerranée on peut le
dire
olivier arnaud ou fernand braudel aussi
quitter oui bien sûr monsieur un petit
un grand un immense chef-d'oeuvre ramos
et quand historiens voilà ils mangent
historiens une hausse historique
mais voilà et marenostrum donc deux et
c'est aux éditions la joie ni voilà ça
dénouement soit sept policiers
[Rires]
on peut peut-être commencer par évoquer
la situation actuelle qui est assez
confuse
on a l'impression que les gens ne
comprennent plus rien à rien c'est à
dire que
les îles sont contre les grèves mais
aussi contre la réforme pour le système
à points mais quand même contre la
réforme des retraites
les sondages sont totalement
contradictoires on a l'impression quand
même que cette réforme du mal à passer
parce que les gens n'y comprenez rien et
que finalement ce conflit ne va faire
que des perdants on al'impression on
pourrait dire que le gouvernement a
gagné puisque finalement la mobilisation
et a tendance à s'effilocher oui voilà à
fait minime même même la grève de
vendredi
voilà n'a pas été aussi puissantes que
le voulait la cgt et pourtant on a
l'impression qu'il n'y a que des
perdants dans ce conflit non enfin c'est
mon impression donc qui veut commencer
ben m'sik des perdants surtout pas c'est
je pense que la france sortira gagnante
on sait très bien qu'on pouvait pas
continuer comme ça donc c'est une
opération financièrement ça tient pas
tout
y'a pas un expert qui assurent qu'ils
font qu'on pouvait laisser les choses en
l'état leurs apparats la cgt ouzou
maintenant de façon absolument mais
abracadabrantesque sont en train de dire
qu'on a le meilleur régime de retraite
actuel il ya trois ans étaient les
premiers pour dire que c'était une
horreur mais maintenant c'est bien le
meilleur régime du monde à le résumer
création pour tous pas changé mais on
sait bien que c'est un régime qui n'est
pas viable
on voit bien y'a pas besoin d'avoir fait
oui mais de deux grandes études savoir
qu' on ne peut pas vu l'espérance de vie
continue à laisser les cheminots ou des
conducteurs de métro prendre leur
retraite à 52 5 mai à torreilles sont
concernés par la réforme et la réforme
du système à points qui est pas une
réforme financière on soit c'est pas
parce que vous passez au système à
points que le le régime et est viable
financièrement non me sera avec
l'allongement de la durée du travail
à cette occasion de choisir des
cotisations ou avec la baisse des
pensions selon la rega trois relevés
mais c'est pas le système à points qui
rendent qui a changé d'âme heures c'est
ça la réforme de base me semble-t-il
oui c'est la réforme systémique comment
dire sur le papier en tout cas ça
paraissait
être une réforme sans doute plus juste
c'est vrai ou du délire par la cfdt qui
a été prônée fut un temps par la cgt le
même il ya quelques il ya quelques
années mais en effet assez assez
incroyable de considérer que le
financement de ce mécanisme n'est
toujours pas fixée bon mais de ce point
de vue là je trouve que le la position
de desmaures philippe fin du
gouvernement en général l'état c'est
assez subtil en disant pas très bien
vous voulez retirer lâche pivot donc
proposer un système qui pourra être
viable mais enfin le risque c'est ce qui
s'est passé à l'égard de l'assurance vie
l'assurance chômage c'est à dire que les
partenaires sociaux ne sont pas parvenus
à son temps et d'auxerre il ya un
gouvernement a pris la main mais qui le
gouvernement apparaît évidemment
beaucoup plus légitime après coup dans
ce genre de dans ce genre de schéma
après un échec du dialogue social mais
vous n'avez pas quand même l'impression
qu'il ya un flou artistique
un vrai flou qui fait que même quand
vous entendez les membres du
gouvernement il n'y a aucun qui ait un
qui est capable d'expliquer exactement
de gosse que sa retraite on découvre
tous les jours par exemple on découvre
que comme l'ailé les gros salaires enfin
seront seront seront moins de retraite
mais l'agirc arrco va avoir un défaut
d'avoir un coût à payer beaucoup plus
plus forts et risquent de se retrouver
en déficit pour des coups tous les
souvent d'aider des effets collatéraux
de cette réforme que semble-t-il perçu
aucun puissant l'utile personne n'avait
pensé non j'ai l'impression que c'est
une stratégie même du gouvernement qui
consistent à pas dire clairement quelles
sont ses intentions pour ensuite c'est
ça qui inquiète les gens et donc les
gens vont quand même manifester en se
disant qu'ils vont le faire pour quelque
chose c'est à dire pour une idée qu'il
croit savoir être celle du gouvernement
mais si c'est pas totalement celle là
celui ci disait ensuite que
les idées qui sont avancés par les
manifestants ne sont pas celles qu'ils
ont définitivement arrêté oui et donc
chacun se renvoie sont floues et ça fait
le jeu du gouvernement qui peut ensuite
espérer poser une réforme bien définis
par lui avec une opposition qui est
complètement éclatés sur le sujet et y
arriver à ses fins donc en pure
technique en pure politique politicienne
je crois que c'est bien réussi mais je
ne crois pas que ça va augmenter la
confiance que les français ont envers le
gouvernement est présent dans le public
moi j'ai l'impression que c'est même le
contraire donc quelques le gouvernement
est en train de perdre dessus d'abord
d'abord parce qu'il a fait beaucoup
d'eux de congestion de concessions sur
ça reste sur sa réforme sur le sol fou
et ensuite parce que finalement il ya
beaucoup de cas il ya évidemment des
perdants donc on fait payer beaucoup de
frustration aussi non il ya beaucoup de
peurs irraisonnées et de t'être et de
délire absolu mais en ce moment on passe
notre temps à entendre des gens sont en
pleine forme nous dire que à 60 ans ils
pourront jamais continuent leur travail
qu'à 58 ans ils sont vides et rincez et
ses données
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ce peuple
qu'est ce que c'est que ces gens fermés
en quoi est ce que la majorité des
boulots ne pas les faire à 58 et jusqu'à
62 64 ans mais je conseille très bien la
pénibilité se comprend très bien qu'un
type qui a passé vingt ans avec un
marteau piqueur à la main qui peut tu
prenne sa retraite à 45 ans si on peut
le lui payer ça sera très bien c'est un
boulot effectivement extrêmement pénible
c'est pas un soin est rarement un mec
qui dit je rêve dans ma vie de tenir un
marteau piqueur mais en revanche un peu
lisse et un pompier une infirmière etc
c'est pas des métiers qu'on fait sous la
contrainte et des métiers parce que on a
le sens de l'engagement on a envie de
soigner des gens ont envie de les sauver
on a envie d'arrêter les méchants arrêté
il faut que tous ces gens arrêtent de
dire il faut qu'on prenne même 13 55 ans
ils sont pas fatigués à 55 ans ou alors
ils sont carrément incompétent incapable
même pas pour ne pas les engager non
mais c'est à dire si ces gens sont sont
finis à 55 ans
vous avez les critères comme la
pénibilité est un critère essentiel dans
sa bien sûr personne n'est égal devant
la pénibilité les 220 théréau des
métiers ne sont pas égaux les gens même
ne sont pas égaux j'aimerais bien
assisté est une petite heure quelques
chèvres être une petite souris assisté
insiste et assister un jour mais
j'espère bien le faire jusqu'à cet âge
là j'aimerais bien assister un jour à
une réunion entre 1 un conducteur de tgv
qui dans une cabine climatisée où je
dirais c'est le principe même du train
peut pas dire qu'il soit emmerder sur le
chemin à suivre jeudi enfin c'est ce
passage à vide moins d'un kilo et puis
avec un type qui effectivement a passé
sa vie avec un marteau piqueur à la main
ou un gardien ou un gardien d'un
surveillant de 2,2 d'établissement
pénitentiaire s'était en fait il faut
arrêter de mélanger tout faire at-elle
un sens et vous dites mais il y avait
quand même quelque chose de très
intéressant qui se peut pas se passer
probablement l'intérêt de la cgt si la
cgt ce qui est on voit quand même perd
un peu dans ce conflit c'est à dire que
un conflit entre martinez mais il ya
aussi le le patron de la cgt rail au
fond qui est très peu suivie
parlez vous avez au vendredi yves dit
tgv sur 10 qui roulait donc jour 2 qui
devait être un jour de mobilisation
internationale
donc ça va être aussi intéressant de
savoir ce qui se passe à l'intérieur de
du syndicat sans compter l'émergence au
sein de la ratp de deux organisations
qui ne sont pour l'instant pas
représentatives puisqu'elles ne se sont
jamais présentés au jamais besoin de
candidats aux élections et qui quand
elles ont été relativement suivie par la
nasa avec un discours extrêmement
radical
là aussi après les fractures du monde
politique le monde syndical et est en
train de changer sous nos yeux
ça c'est vrai qu'au point de changer et
malheureusement pas pour forcément pour
se renforcer a malheureusement
peut-être qu'il ya des points de vue ou
tournoi je pense que c'est malheureux
d'avoir des syndicats profile en france
sur ce sujet non effectivement je trouve
que c'est triste que on est cette
tradition en france où les effectivement
le il n'y a pas une confiance direct au
niveau des corps intermédiaires
je crois que les français alors ce qu'il
faut le voir comme une forme de défiance
en verre une sorte de démocratie de
proximité et une plus grande espérance
confiance c'est pas le mot mais
l'espérance dans la politique qui doit
être conduite par les représentants
nationaux
je crois que c'est dommage je crois
qu'il faudrait que les français puissent
effectivement sa culture et à 7 cette
logique syndicale mais ce n'est pas le
cas en france tant que ça c'est assez
malheureux mais je crois que les
syndicats sont eux mêmes responsables de
cette défiance
oui parce qu'il n'ya pas de et qu'est ce
qu'il faudrait faire une adhésion
obligatoire ça ne marche pas par visage
a aussi c'est le vrai visage à bhl
illégal d'ailleurs c'est très bon pour
eux si juste honnête est conseillé aussi
aux français et aux râleurs invétérés de
regarder un peu ce qui se passe en
dehors des frontières de l'hexagone et
devoirs en allemagne par exemple des
syndicats forts non mais les syndicats
forts mais je n'arrête pas de bosser à
52 ans
partout mais pas partout où le combo
stretta vous venez oui certes eu et je
reste persuadé qu'on peut
c'est que c'est un but dans la vie de
famille très un peut s'éclater dans le
boulot c'est très bien d'avoir masqué
gazaouis ont peu on pourrait fonder une
société sur autre chose mais en plus
osés mais constante aux autres et en
plus on a cassé l'idée c'est un problème
c'est que la plupart des gens qui ont 58
60 ans se font mettre au chômage
c'est difficile de trouver des emplois
souvent dans les grandes entreprises je
préfère que ce soit les les le système
du chômage qui dépérit plutôt qu'eux
mêmes ils ont caché des gens moins bien
payés à leur place et il c'est vrai que
la difficulté pour les heures à partir
d'une soixantaine d'années de travail et
les fortes et voilà on peut leur dire
travaillent plus longtemps travailler
plus enfin nexans qui est contradictoire
vous êtes en train de dire que les gens
de 58 à 60 ans voudrait travailler il
était de travailler
peut-être pas les mêmes mais c'est pour
ça que je pense que c'est très
individuelle point le rapport à là où
travaillent et le rapport à la
pénibilité le rapport non individuelle
subjectif effectif comme celui de
l'histoire de chacun baum à zéro la
trace et la bêtise est simple à faire la
salle et pour des gens ça dépend de du
ressenti ça dépend de société quand même
depuis depuis des lustres fondée sur le
lin certain épanouissement qu un
accomplissement par le travail alors
tout à fait que avec les 35 heures on
est massacrée cette idée même du travail
le travail ne servait à rien que c'est
très bien mais ça dit non non il n'avait
une productivité je crois qu'il a plus
fortes au monde mais des 35 heures mais
beaucoup de productivité n'est pas tout
on sait bien que l'oise yves tu es la
mère de tous les vices
on leur propose rien d'autre lançait à
le boulot c'est pas bien vous pressez
gatti dans le boulot c'est pas l'argent
sera bien y'a rien et bien ok parfait
mais qu'est ce qui est bien et il n'y a
pas de solution il ya rien de bien voilà
je veux bien qu'en france la grève ait
l'air d'être un loisir merveilleux la
manifestation etc
on peut pas baser tout sur ce
manifestation qui se sent fin c'est
alors maintenant ils ont même et enfin
la semaine dernière la retraite aux
flambeaux maintenant le poids pour
manifester afin de faire de la russie
esthétiquement ça manquait la neige ça
devient d'oisiveté la mère de tous les
vices et moselle que c'est pour ça que
les moines se lève très tôt 1 que s'il
restait audi vis de moi je leur ai des
idées
alors qu'est ce qui est très intéressant
et peut-être étonnant c'est que voilà on
a l'impression qu'on est dans un marasme
des conflits dans ton certes se repasse
un peu plus de 58 jours et c'est enfin
c'est dur et en même temps si on regarde
les chiffres
peut-être que la france va mieux et
c'est l'événement alors je dis la france
va mieux c'est à dire que on a vu le
président de la république recevoir à
versailles tous les ans une centaine en
tout cas de deux chefs de grandes
entreprises représentant plus de 40
nationalités différentes et à cette
occasion
c'est un peu venté de ne s'est pas
offert tout cas l'un des cif en disant
voilà la france est en train de
reprendre
c'est vrai que si on regarde les
chiffres c'est pas tout à fait faux on
peut sans peut s'en réjouir après il ya
juste un petit bémol c'est que
la france reste très attractive mais
est-ce que c'est pas aussi parce que le
reste de l'europe l'est de moins en
moins parce que je veux dire on va dire
que l'allemagne soit un truc qui fasse
rêver en ce moment économiquement donc
on peut comprendre qu'on s'installe plus
sexy
l'italie et l'espagne sont des pays que
j'adore acteurs on peut pas dire que ce
non plus au top de l'efficacité donc
voila c est ce que c'est pas un peu par
défaut des kits année en europe on est
un peu contraint les en france donc
voilà ce que je m'en réjouis quand même
et puis après la chose un tout petit peu
embêtant c'est que toutes ces sociétés
sont effectivement des sociétés
étrangères
donc tout l'argent repart en fait ne
reste pas en france ça crée de l'emploi
si l'investisseur s'équipent nos mères
ce qu'ils investissent et mais les
bénéfices après repart des dividendes
revoilà donc voilà c'est ça serait bien
qu'ils étaient français se développe
aussi et que ça soit juste l'échelle
humaine de sous traitance 10 ha soit
positive mais je me suis fait mal comme
ça pour eux si j'avais réfléchi à la
question
une spirale positive à la cause mais
c'est vrai que les siffle le chômage
baisse l'investissement reprendre et on
est passé enfin la france gagner des
places de deuxième
payés d'europe dans lequel on n'investit
c'est vrai que c'est des chiffres plutôt
positifs
et vous imaginez les cif ne veut pas eu
les gilet jaune savait pas les grèves
très bizarre très bizarre seulement de
la très bizarrement ça des affluences
évidemment notamment sur le commerce
mais sur le niveau macroéconomique c'est
très attractive d'elles mêmes dans les
chiffres enfin ça n'a pas d'influencé
même sur le sur l'économie proprement
dit
même s'il ya des victimes de ces
conflits notamment les commerçants
attendent sur ce sujet sur ce sujet oui
enfin c'est il faut enfin il ya 2 il ya
deux tableaux ci voulait ya ce que je
lisais
une interview de jean louis etienne
médecin explorateur qui disait les
français se plaignent la bouche pleine
c'est parfois vrai bon le le tout les
français n'ont pas la bouche pleine
ça ça c'est un fait mais il ya un siècle
que la pauvreté alors de il ya des
critères qui sont tout à fait discutable
des seuils qui sont tout à fait
discutable que la qui a une volant
toujours d'à peu près 8 millions de
personnes en france qui sont dans une
situation de très grande qualité et
cetera et c'est ça qu'on peut trouver
pour le moins étonnant c'est à dire que
d'un côté ça va mieux alors ça peut pas
être instantané mais de l'autre on
laisse quand même sur le bord de la
route
beaucoup de gens beaucoup trop en tout
cas les solutions mois les solutions
miracles je crois qu'elle n'existe pas
je ne les ai pas en tout cas je ne je ne
sais pas si d'appauvrir les riches entre
guillemets parce que là aussi je sais
pas si la démo voilà à partir de quand
on est on est riche pour enrichir les
pauvres je ne sais pas si c'est la
solution j'en doute en tout cas ce que
je sais c'est que notre système
en effet notre système social politico
sociale est l'un des plus redistributifs
sinon le plus gros distributeur le plus
au monde
alors il ya peut-être une question aussi
d'efficacité de nos systèmes qui doit
être mise sur la table mais en tout cas
on est là dans cette dans cette espèce
de miroirs de symétrie qui apparaît
quand même à la fois
choquant est paradoxal votre liste c'est
typiquement français
c'est cette passion que nous avons pour
l'égalité qui remonteraient à très très
loin et qui fait qu' on ne se contente
pas de comment dirais-je de chiffres
économiques éloquent c'est une réaction
qui serait plutôt américaine et en
france l'idée est plutôt de comparer ces
résultats avec le partage des richesses
et de ce point de vue là effectivement
les chiffres que vous donnez sa campagne
aussi d'autres chiffres qui sont ceux de
la captation des richesses par
par les plus riches n'y avait là une
étude de l'oxfam c'est une j'ai
absolument dirigée par l'ancien lise
dufour d'actifs logés en france
en france tout à perdre on sera sauvés
et qui donne des chiffres assez
incroyable le creusement des inégalités
vont le good du type qui économise 8000
euros depuis la révolution française
c'est vraiment du grand grand n'importe
quoi
ac oui oui rendez vous compte alors à
propos de la fortune de bernard arnault
est une fortune mais qu'est ce qu'une
fortune d'entreprise une fortune
d'actifs économique qui n'est pas une
fortune oui l'argent qu'il a la barre
des deux milliards de dollars sur son
compte
cécile duflot elle le décrit comme une
sorte de picsou qu'au respect des normes
coffre fort avec des nids viard
maintenant ma non c'est pas ça
c'est une fortune d'entreprise je pense
qu'il fait je suis pas il doit faire
bosser cent mille cent mille salariés en
france je crois c'est le premier
contribuable de france
donc ce ce cette échelle qui consiste à
dire si une personne avait depuis 1789
économiser 8000 euros par mois ils
n'auraient que 1 % de la fortune de
bernard arnault s'est franchement
grotesque
je vous ai absolument gros c'est risible
oui ça oui mais mais quand même les noms
voyez ce serait ça quand même un effet
sur vous vous dites oh non mais quand
même non
je veux dire l'idée quand même qu'il ya
un petit pourcentage de riches qui sont
de plus en plus riches aliments
c'est quand même vrai ça oui mais
admirez le sait cette figure qu'on nous
présente le bilan type qui ré économies
partout depuis cro magnon l'homme
préhistorique qui aurait économisé
générés par en août
et cet abruti de cro magnon n'y a pas
pensé
ce qui permit de deux euros de côté mais
quand même non mais c'est c'est vrai
qu'on est en dés dans une vieille a en
effet des facteurs comme ça qu'ils se
qui se contredisent en effet vous le
disiez en est sans doute l'un des pays
qui est peut-être le pays qui
redistribue le plus et en même temps il
ya quand même dans un phénomène mondial
auquel la france appartient une un
accaparement des richesses par un faible
pourcentage de très très riche voilà qui
détiennent quand même le leurs richesses
du monde et ce qui n'empêche pas la
grande pauvreté de reculer à l'échelle
mondiale ce qui n'empêche pas la
comprendre
vraiment je sais pas où vous vient ce je
crois que c'est l'onu c'est un milliard
de de deux personnes qu'il ya 20 ans
était dans une très grande pauvreté qui
ne sont plus alors disons pas dans une
situation venez ses serments viable mais
qui ne sont plus en tout cas dans une
infinie pauvreté en même temps oui les
raisons de le dire il ya une
concentration des richesses entre les
mains d'un nombre très faible de
personnes l'ont utilisé
on peut aussi médecin à l'échelle à
l'échelle nationale en perspective avec
le traitement que le pouvoir politique
va avoir vis-à-vis d'eux pour
schématiser disons entre le les riches
d'un côté enfin les très riches et les
personnes qui sont en situation de
pauvreté
voyez par exemple le président de
république qui reçoit c'est aux chefs
d'entreprise à versailles qui est un
lieu extrêmement symbolique et de
l'autre côté ces personnes dans une
situation de précarité qui ont pu à
juste titre se sentir mais pris par
certains propos tenus par le président
de la république et je crois que delà de
la situation matérielle
au-delà de ces chiffres est aussi une
une manière d'aborder les choses et
d'aborder les situations par le pouvoir
politique qui qui mal perçue par par le
peuple voulait c'est pas le président de
la république reçoive les des grands
patrons sous une tente dans ce domaine
65 cents à des normes et sans à des
transformers vice versa et merci non
mais parce que le château non mais
versailles c'est quand même un lieu
extrêmement symbolique peut pas faire
comme si le symbole n'était pas là qui
est quand même rattachée à la royauté on
a partiellement république y extrêmement
puissant extrêmement fort on va pas te
plaît le plus personne atteinte à la
royauté on appelle ça à l'ab à la
magnificence de la france à l'efficacité
de la france pour avoir conservé un
patrimoine à quelque chose qu'il est
resplendissant et kiki qui valorise des
gens qui sont invités cette
extraordinaire pour un chef d'entreprise
américain qui vit au fin fond du texas
qui sait même pas ce que c'est qu'un
truc en pierre
je dérive arrive au château de
versailles va venir il est baba et c'est
ça la france
heureusement on va pas c'est pas tant la
réception à versailles qui en est même
choquant mais ces contrastes cette fois
c'est sûr qu'il est en parallèle elle
n'a pas disons d égard du pouvoir
politique vis-à-vis du peuple en tout
cas du petit peu c'est à dire qu'on fait
avec un mépris quand même extrêmement
fort et c'est ce contraste là qui est
saisissant et qui fait que les francs
fin une part importante des français
sont extrêmement extrêmement jamais le
réseau nettement le qualificatif
président des riches alors après c'est
vrai c'est pas vrai c'est peut-être
parce que nîmes enfin c'est un des
reproches qui lui est fait le plus
souvent
oui c'est un reproche qui est fait mais
qui n'est pas partagé par tout le monde
d'abord m'adapter il éclata stable parce
qu'il ya des gens qu'il ya des gens qui
pensent ça mais je honnêtement je vois
je vois pas en quoi
macro et méprisant avec le petit peuple
dont vous parlez c'est par exemple le
cas pourquoi vidéo type
il suffit de traverser la rue pour
trouver du boulot même même un maquereau
ont trouvé de cette phrase n'aurait pas
dû être prononcées oui mais non non mais
on peut on peut la considérer comme un
peu méprisante capacité des gens qui ne
sont rien en parlant des faits qui
peuplent au togo il ya des forces qui
sont faire des problèmes voilà pour
border sur la démocratie n'est peut-être
qu'il faut faire attention aussi quand
vous menez quand on exerce une fonction
politique
donc vous êtes deux adeptes de la langue
de bois total c'est dire qu'on ne dit
rien on continue endormir légende à ton
patelin on est ton pistolet secoue
chiraquien non mais l'avenir à partir
d'environ cacher des vérités
ben oui il ya les gens qui ne sent rien
et ce que j'ai réussi c'est à dire une
vérité d'emploi non pourvues en france
oui mais non mais il ya plus de six cent
mille emplois non pourvus en quoi est-ce
que c'était faux de la part d' emmanuel
macron du président de dire ok ben on
peut aussi se bouger et alors voilà il
n'y a rien de méprisant
après on reçoit les choses de finir
de gens qui l'ont reçue comme ça oui
d'accord décote quand on réfléchit avec
un peu de recul on peut dire que c'était
pas si méprisant que ça c'est pas s'il
faut que ça après je comprends que des
gens les malpris mais je connais tu mens
si c'est pas si méprisant que ça c'est
exactement comme quand il a lui dit on
met un peu de ça reprend un peu le
propos stéphane tout à l'heure où on met
un pognon des dingues et c'est pas très
efficace ok la parole et peut-être pas
belle mais elle est juste si on peut on
peut tout dire de la france et du
gouvernement de maquereaux et même des
gouvernements précédents du gouvernement
hollande du gouvernement de sarkozy
il met tout ce qu'ils ont tous mis un
pognon de dengue dans les tas de choses
avec une efficacité toute relative
et bien c'est tout à fait moi ça me
rassure que le président de la
république actuel se dit voilà comment
on peut faire pour que ça fonctionne
mieux c'est paris les prix là dedans
il n'a pas dans la façon de s'adresser
parfois des envois il ya une spontanéité
qui rappelle celle de sarkozy oui une
main sur moi qui ai peut-être pas
suffisamment puissant de temps en temps
mais là le coup de traverser la rue
brigitte macro lallaoui j'ai lu ça je la
regrette
il était juste avant qu'il faut quoi
oui et le restaurateur parle avec eux et
leur ai dit moi quelqu'un traverse la
rue et vient l'amoureuse galant je lui
donne et président de la rosa numérique
ou tard à william puisqu'on est dans le
nord et l'économie il ya évidemment les
troisièmes davos et il ya eu le discours
de trump qui était intéressant fin qui
surprenait ou toujours un peu climato
sceptiques je pense qu'ils s'en
prenaient au parangon du pessimisme
dix ans que la période est pas fait pour
le pessimisme et mais pour les petits
misme et que ben voilà on a toujours
prévu des crises de la famine massive
dans les années 70 la fin du pétrole
dans les années 80 et en gros il le dit
pas mais la crise climatique dans les
années 2020
moi je me demande si le greta tanberg
n'est pas l'idiote utile de dire que
grâce à elle
n'importe quel discours de trump
pourrait finir par dire mais finalement
c'est pas si débile parce que quand on
entend ce que great attenberg a osé dire
en arrivant avec avec cette espèce de
fausse candeur en dur il faut tout
arrêter il faut plus rien faire on
s'arrête tout on débranche les usines on
débranche oui ça travaille plus mais on
déduit la noire est cliniquement et pour
le chauffage sais pas si toute personne
qui parle
après greta tenir n'importe quelle
connerie on se bat et un bal à cette
façon c'est moins idiot alors bon bah du
coup ça va aider hop on dit
finalement maintien il ya des phrases un
sujet un verbe complément c'est une
préface mélouze l'hôte d'un qui oserait
là qu'on arpente de belles son auditoire
de 3000 trump plutôt que deux greta oui
j'espère que non enfin je bon mais où la
peste ou le choléra
il ya quelques années on se serait dit
le président des états unis est en
campagne électorale ce qui est le cas et
donc ça va très loin dans la surenchère
verbale dans l'agressivité etc
mais enfin ce qu'il ya de marrant avec
trump c'est que au fond c'est tout le
temps donc il est tout le temps au
taquet dans la surenchère dans l'excès
dans l'irresponsabilité
il a un côté de lapin duracell il
s'arrête jamais jamais
fermât noreen s'arrête jamais enfin
tweeté à fins et c'est quand même
fascinant jeu
historiquement dans dans quelques
décennies mais une fois qu'on aura pris
du recul par rapport à ce personnage et
à cette situation ce sera extrêmement
intéressant de l'étudier de près c'est
le sait le dire c'est le nom de quoi
train d'en baisser
c'est un phénomène quand même de
gouvernance d'aujourd'hui face et c'est
un symbole quand même de notre société
ou ses valises au laisser la tête de
pont de huy la figure de proue de tout
un tout un mouvement tout un phénomène
populiste s'était enfin et avec après si
on enlève un peu légumes des choses et
c'est fondamentalement il faudra aussi
de temps en temps parler de la réalité
économique des états unis là est ce que
c'est si mauvais train pour l'économie
des états unis
je suis pas certains contestataires qui
ont dit à 3 et 10% de chômage mais en
réalité et si on calculait comme nous ça
fait deux fois plus ça fait 7 % mais il
ya quand même un endettement absolument
colossal oui bah tu sais pas si on peut
vraiment lui donner des leçons mais un
nom mais on est d'accord mais comme il a
baissé considérablement les rangs des
impôts c'est vrai il ya aussi une façade
comme ça qui est plutôt plutôt bon après
il peut y avoir aussi des problèmes
économiques intérim derrière mais on
sent huit ans il aura autant de faire
des choses qui est ce qui est assez
fascinant
ce qu'il fait c'est facile on là ils
allaient se retrouver dans une
manifestation anti avortement alors que
il ya quelques années il avait défendu
l'avortement réseau il est prêt à tout
quand même assez se contredit au même
avec un désinvolture absolue mais au
fond il est peut-être à l'image
il est à l'image du corps électeurs
il est comme beaucoup de populiste une
espèce de bouchons de liège qui flotte
sur les vagues et qui vogue au gré du
goût gré du courant
bon il va là où le vent le maine et jeu
balle et les électeurs sont adultes une
peuvent en effet être choqués on réagir
mais c'est pas le cas manifestement il
part pour être votre rêve
et oui d'autant que dans le camp d'en
face on sait pas très bien comment ça va
se passer
nous lancerons pas trop il ya enfin ça
c'est toujours cela dit c'est un système
absolument incroyable a regardé comme le
système américain parce que c'est vrai
que à chaque fois arrive des gens que
personne ne connaît enfin sony machines
qui peuvent être président et qui
finissent par être élu c'est c'est c'est
vrai que c'est facile pour nous c'est un
jean baptiste on parlera mieux que mon
frère est un vieux système
enfin vieillot poussiéreux mékinac et
n'a pas qui n'a pas évolué avec cette
histoire des délégués ce caucus ce
système qui consiste à voter tous les
deux ans enfin la présence à tous les
quatre ans mais il ya deux il ya des
îles et les grandes élections tous les
2e et avec dédé des taux de
participation qui culmine à 100 % dans
les même dans le meilleur des cas
enfin c'est un système qui a abouti à ce
que celui qui a le moins de voix soit
soit élu il n'y a pas qu'aux états unis
elle avait rien aussi à la mairie de
paris vous vient au royaume-uni facile
effectivement système constitutionnel
qui permet pas une projection à long
terme sur la politique comme le disent
effectivement stéphane président qui est
perpétuellement en campagne électorale
ce qui peut favoriser effectivement en
tout cas l'outrance si populiste ia et
puis aussi un système qui est conçu mais
c'est plutôt le système mais aussi le
plus tôt le peuple américain et son
histoire qui qui est conscient en
permettant à ceux qui finalement arrive
à capter le plus grand nombre de
richesses à parvenir aux responsabilités
les forces de l'argent sont extrêmement
importants de la force des lobbys et
donc il ya d'abord un travail qui se
fait à ce niveau là autour de ces
puissances de l'argent et c'est
d'ailleurs mal vus c'était une personne
qui n'arrive pas à capter suffisamment
d'argent est vu comme un autre candidat
qui n'est pas forcément responsable et
qui va pas pouvoir assumer un pays ça en
dit long sur la manière dont les
français consomment le la politique en
général
et quand dans ce système là d'argent et
d'un système qui ne permet pas des
projections à long terme sur le plan
politique on ajoute le populisme
effectivement ça ça fait quelque chose
d'explosif ont mais c'est intéressant
parce que des gens comme mon elisabeth
onekey gauche ou sanders qui est à
gauche trouve aussi des des financements
et oui mais parce que c'est en fait le
la gauche et chez eux ce que ce qu'elle
pourrait être chez nous au niveau de la
droite mais met à travailler le
socialiste oui mais non mais d'accord
mais dans l'uemoa
mais sur le rapport à l'argent il n'ya
pas véritable qu'après sur le plan des
politiques sociales s'était remise sur
l'argent après est-ce que ce que
l'irruption de deux gens que personne ne
connaît que vous dénonciez la plus à
l'aise que c'est si négatif que saab
soit un marchand de cacahuètes un peu un
playboy héritier est un ancien acteur
enfin je les invite non échangées à
scott lui placé pendant mais on va
parler de ces doux dans un instant mais
pendant très longtemps et c'est à
changer avec macro notamment mais
pendant très longtemps à se présenter
trois fois présidence de la république
avant d'être élu et comme le terran
député général sénateur au ministre
c'est alors que alors que aux états unis
à l'exception peut-être de nixon
quelqu'un qui a été battu une fois aux
présidentielles il disparaît enfin
disparaître du jeu politique
peut-être qu'on est en train d'arriver
ce système aussi enfin on voit justement
banal les états dits on dit souvent que
c'est la plus grande démocratie du monde
mais est ce que notre démocratie elle
est en crise c'est l'éclairage on peut
reprendre quelques faits vous avez vu le
président mal tron qui va au théâtre
digne un tweet qu'il dénonçait des gens
qui viennent qui viennent manifester des
manifestants qui qui manifestent aux
cris de macron vad et chercher la
rotonde qui a pris bizarrement feu
le siège de la cfdt qui a été saccagé
on en avait parlé mais c'est vrai que il
ya plein de deux penseurs qui sont
interdits de parole dans les universités
qui sont le lieu même de la de la parole
violences policières contre évidence de
manifestants ça pose quand même un
problème de notre démocratie
pourquoi d'abord pourquoi il ya l'été
autour de 2,2 de haine de violence de on
a l'impression qu'il est comme ça dès
qu'on est irréductible et est-ce que ça
pose en effet un problème de
représentation de démocratie sûrement ce
que ce qui me trouble dans tout ça c'est
qu'en fait j'ai l'impression que plus
personne ne se condamner quoi que ce
soit et que c'est aussi pour ça que tous
développent c'est à dire que par exemple
devrait devrait vraiment faire quelque
chose contre les syndicalistes qui
coupent l'électricité de façon illégale
absolument et ils sont dans l'illégalité
et finalement je dis pas que tout le
monde trouve ça très bien mais on les a
mis 2 heures en garde à vue a augmenté
en géant du web on sait pas trop si
c'est ça l'europe c'est pas grave ça
passe à la trappe
donc c'est une sorte de blanc sans dents
alesi continuent et continuent à faire
les choses on a un type qui est là
quasiment train de dénoncer et d'appeler
quasiment au lynchage du président de la
république parce qu'ils les trois rangs
derrière
au lieu de dire ce type est une crapule
est en tout cas un agitateur politique
la majorité des gens dire ah oui c'est
un journaliste a la rage
un journaliste militant vrai qu'on
m'explique ce que c'est que cette
nouvelle notion qui est très dangereux
pour la démocratie
journalisme militant est ce que c'est de
dire aux étudiants quand j'en ai soit
militant ce journaliste et on est
militant quand on a fini son boulot de
journaliste ainsi sur les décors vous
vous voyez la région de la ville de
certain abdou on peut pas dire que c'est
pas des journalistes militants les
barrières actuelles restent des journaux
avec des gens quelqu'un de yade
ils font bien leur boulot mais je veux
dire ce type qui dit jeunes en mai 2006
mais le journalisme s'annoncer pas
existé c'est pas la même origine je
crois toujours à l'honnêteté
journalistique terre que on peut on peut
être militant du socialiste ou militants
des répliques historiques et faire un
papy dit auriez c'est différent et faire
un papier à peu près objectif sur la
réalité des choses
on n'est pas c'est pas ces opinions
politiques qui doivent gouverner
enfin et mener la plume du journaliste
un éditorialiste c'est différent mais là
on est en train de mélanger dans
n'importe quel crétin qui est un cas un
iphone qui lors d'une manifestation sais
pas mais je ne suis pas un péquin moyen
je suis journaliste
un journaliste ou non c'est pas un site
de droite ou de gauche
on a un mélange tout et c'est le social
j'espère que les paroles de dix jours si
j'y suis qui étaient d'anciennes
émissions de rue alors mais un français
peut pas dire que ce soit le modèle au
monde
delaunay de l'objectif j'aurai un violon
un vieux débat sur lequel on pourrait
donner des exemples très contradictoires
dont je me laisse en parler d'
objectivité il ya des il ya une
déontologie journalistique qui n'a pas
été complètement bafouée par cette
personne lorsqu'il a qui n'a pas la
carte de presse donnée qui n'a pas la
carte de presse et c'est l'onu qui
dépasse et karine l'honneur de la presse
qui ne l'est pas kiki qui a prétendu que
à l'occasion d'une occupation de locaux
universitaires il ya un an et demi les
locaux de pas rien sans pierre
mendès-france que le sang coulait et que
avant l'arrivée de la presse les crs
éponger le sens des étudiants qui
avaient été massacrés et c est en effet
c'était absolument faux donc
je crois que c'est en effet de l'honneur
de la profession de journaliste qu'il
n'est pas sa carte
il était par ailleurs candidat la france
où miles dans l'isère aux précédentes
législatives ce qui n'est pas interdit
aux journalistes
absolument je suis d'accord mais là là
là ce procédé se avec ce tweet qui est
quand même plus que j'allais dire
tendance n'est pas un truc d'information
dénonciation de dénonciation en tout cas
de de l'addition d'atteinte à la vie
privée vous après tout cela roide
absolument trop d'appuis et d'aller au
théâtre
mais au-delà de ça alors quand même
cette atmosphère de haine semble-t-il
enfin non oui bien sûr on en est après
on peut l'arrêter visé c'est vrai que je
viens il faut rappeler que je sais pas
j'ai eu combien 20 attentats contre
contre de gaulle qui vous et sa mort
était que l'ailé des armées nommé
prestation des années 30 était une sorte
de beaucoup plus violent qu'elle roule
entre elles notent sont aujourd'hui les
enfants la vie politique la vie
politique
les discours bien sérieuse cours qui
était tenue au sein même de l'assemblée
nationale jeu à l'époque j'avais déjà
vais travailler tue pour autre chose
mais j'avais été horrifiée quand on lit
ce qui se disait sur blum de léon blum
camping étaient présents du conseil vrai
c'était la mort enfin c'était des appels
à l'amour au sein de l'assemblée
nationale est actuellement un
antisémitisme vie épouvantables donc le
pays a connu notre démocratie que c'est
notre ville qui comme ça au bout
au fond c'est la vraie question
ressurgit de temps en temps avec plus ou
moins de me dire je je je vois ça comme
un justement le symptôme d'une alors
d'une démocratie qui est malade pas
forcément mais d'une démocratie qui qui
qui qui qui poussent parfois vers
l'excès mais tant que c'est de là que
cette parole
on reste dans le cadre démocratique
quand ça devient quand les camps les
paroles se transformant en actions ou en
gestes
là on sort du cadre démocratique la
démocratie c'est la canalisation de la
violence par le discours je peux être
violent dans mon discours
si tenté que je respecte un cadre
minimum qui est celui de ne pas passer à
l'acte justement pas passer à l'action
là il ya eu on est sur la connaît sur
l'avc avec quand même des formations
politiques lors macron en parle est
apparemment hier soir ou cette nuit où
ce matin dans 'la dans l'avion ni
distraire leur reproche d'être de nature
des ponts des sommes en dictature sommes
en régime autoritaire alors fascistes
fascistes vous n'êtes fasciste et vous
pensez pas comme l'extrême gauche donc
je suis de ce point de vue là fasciste
je suis ce que je suis absolument ravi
d'apprendre ça me fait très plaisir je
croyais pas l'être mais romain on m'a
dit oui c'est du fascisme cela voilà
donc tout temps dans la canton quand on
sort de cette mesure si vous voulez le
en effet le discours n'est plus possible
et puis au delà on en parlait tout à
l'heure avec les coûts des six cent
mille voix le ce discours qui consiste à
dire untel est mal élu macron est élu
avec 20% des voix etc
c'est complètement biaisé pourquoi parce
que c'est un système électoral n'est pas
parfait mais il y en a aucun on nous
parlait du système américain alors il
faut s qu'il faut introduire une dose de
proportionnelle oui c'est un conte et
sami il va falloir qu'on y vienne
oui notamment liés hâtives alors mais
c'est c'est enfin en tout cas
philosophiquement politiquement
juridiquement faut que de dire que untel
est mal ou en bien et lui on élu mais
est ce que quand même le système et jean
baptiste théorique on voulait de la vème
république et donc donne tous les
pouvoirs à quelqu'un qui tue qui et je
ne remets pas en cause le score du
premier tour ils disent qu'il est devant
les autres donc bon peu importe mais mes
études et qui désigne des oppositions
qui ne représente pas forcément
l'ensemble l'ensemble de la population
est ce que c'est parce que c'est pas un
système quand même et à bout de souffle
moi je moi je ne crois pas moi je crois
que le
nous traversons arrive traverse une
crise qui est certaine qu'il faut aussi
relativiser si on regarde les choses à
l'échelle de l'histoire
si on prend la 3ème république par
exemple il ya eu des scandales canal du
panama le boulangisme qu'on a des
décorations enfin des crises extrêmement
fort qu'on retrouve pas de manière aussi
comparables sous la vème république et
et la république troisième républicain
durée extrêmement le temps elle a même
survécu à une guerre donc je disons que
je crois que la crise et les elle est
plutôt à mon avis
lié à la surmédiatisation moins
d'événements qui vont être présents là
on continue dans les chaînes continuent
on avait déjà un peu au débat évidemment
il ya plusieurs plusieurs médias
plusieurs manières de conduire le
travail de journalisme mais la plupart
des gens regardent les chaînes
d'information continue et ont accès à
ces images de violence extrême de
manifestants d'une hauteur de deux
policiers d'autre part et effectivement
ça servait de ce média utilisation et
sentiments je ne sais pas si c'est un
sentiment enfin ressenti d'impunité
totale pour beaucoup de gens c'est à
dire que on prend une tractopelle pour
défoncer une porte de ministères ou les
séries cultes heures mais non c'était
pas les agriculteurs a muté en plein air
mais je veux dire non mais il ya eu
aussi des modèles des manifestations
dans toute l'histoire qui lie les
cultures notamment parce que c'était le
cas quand il y en a il y en a de plus en
plus vers l'est des exactions des îles
et jaune je compte quand même par arnaud
wezen qu'est ce qui s'est passé rien là
si si si si si si cette condamnation est
une augmentation si on peut me dire ça
non mais je pense que objecter que ce
que ces gens là des recettes sur la cfdt
il se passe rien voilà le lot le la
visite de macron la beauté a parlé on a
des tonnes mais au fait quand on regarde
les foyers 15 personnes sauf du phrasé
sait pas grand chose c'est aisé oui j'ai
nettement c'est parfois ironiquement
c'est tentant de déplacer le président
calderon le truc donc voilà c'est le
point de vue images sont assez c'est
plus un problème qui domine c'est vrai
qu'on a aussi un regard biaisé par parle
pas l'importance des chaînes d'info
continue me semble-t-il mis en place je
pense que c'est plus un problème qui
touche à la à la personne du président
république
en lien avec le mépris que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure plus qu à l'institution
présidentielle en tant que tel et pour
répondre jusqu'au bout à la question je
crois qu'au contraire moi la vème
république qui est un régime en fin
politique à un régime constitutionnel
qui est extrêmement équilibrée qui tient
compte des forces et des contradictions
de notre histoire puisque on a une
histoire continue elle est extrêmement
augmenté on a connu finalement les deux
excès il excède un pouvoir exécutif trop
fort avec les deux empires les
restaurations et un parlement un
parlementarisme exacerbée aussi et le
système qui a été pensée par le général
de gaulle et michel debré est
extrêmement équilibrée même si on a
plutôt un exécutif fort on a aussi un
parlement qui peut mettre en échec toute
politique envisagée par le gouvernement
sur l'autorité du président république
et je crois qu'au contraire notre notre
système est parfaitement adapté à la
situation et disons à la manière dont
aux rapports disant qu'ils ont aussi des
français à la politique puisque une
constitution doit être adaptée à chaque
fois qu'il ya un rééquilibrage entre
l'exécutif et législatives avec un geste
le plus représentatif grâce à la
proportionnelle notamment
ça éviterait un peu ce effectivement eu
un si on prévoit plus de proportionnelle
ça permet une plus grande
représentativité des différents courants
d'expression mais le problème c'est que
les français et on part fait totalement
passionné en politique
ils n'arrivent pas à s'entendre à avoir
nous n'y a pas de majorité parfaitement
stable n'est pas pas l'hymne suisse ou
allemand et donc on n'arrive pas à
conduire des politiques au hohlandsbourg
ce qui est extrêmement problématique et
effet qu on aurait donc un système
constitutionnel qu'on a connus sous la
troisième république qui ne permet pas
d'avoir de répondre efficacement disons
aux problèmes économiques et sociaux et
donc en raison de cela je crois qu'il
faut pas toucher à cela et qu'il faut
prendre le problème là où il est c'est
plutôt sur le plan économique social et
peut-être aussi médiatique quant à
vivons-nous aux dictatures jeu je
renvoie trait aux textes de comte
sponville qui disent ils imaginent voilà
une société dans dix quinze ans aux
mains des gaffes à aux mains de ou des
gens sont sur les réseaux sociaux ne
sont plus livrés tout ça et il ya des
gens qui comme ça dit mais ça serait
quand même formidable un régime où
toutes les opinions pourrait s'exprimer
hors des ddd télé partout on pourrait
dire on pourrait critiquer le président
de la république est il du bain cette
société idéale c'est là notre dossier et
je trouve que c'est un très beau texte
on va terminer par le débat avec cette
affaire assez étrange la faire de cet
isérois je crois
qu'ils s'appellent milla il veut résumer
cette affaire jean charles peut-être oui
enfin avec beaucoup de geeks de la
perfection ses neveux de prudence donc
c'est une jeune femme qui discutaient
sur internet avec un certain nombre de
gens autour de forums si j'ai bien
compris et l'on vient à discuter avec un
garçon et bout de certains moments de
discussion
elle renvoie le garçon mais gentiment
dans ses cordes en disant que non
c'était pas une discussion sexuelle afin
que je n'ai pas l'intention de d'aller
plus loin sur ce terrain là et c est là
l
d'après ce que j'ai pu en voir et ce que
j'aime et relire les conduit gentiment
et où sans aucun mépris que lui le prend
à l'évidence très mal puisqu'il la
traite de sale et que là ça
démarre sur ce plan là et que du coup
lui étant musulman elle lui répond qu
elle a une vision d'une religion remplis
de haine etc
et là c'est un déchaînement elle est
assaillie de menaces et de menaces de
viol en donne le lycée ils l'ont chargé
de 10 ans qu'elle est réalisée ne peut
plus aller dans son lycée elle est là
elle dit maintenant depuis trois jours
entouré de gardes du corps enfin il ya
un déchaînement de 2,2 de violence
absolument démentielle et alors point
d'orgue ou là on s'aperçoit qu'on est
vraiment en france et nulle part
ailleurs
c'est que avec cette histoire là contre
qui portons plainte contre 7 profite
pour incitation à la haine raciale parce
qu'elle a dit que
la religion et s être une religion de
haine alors voilà c'est quand même c'est
un montant elle et il ya aussi une autre
plainte afin qu est portée contre ceux
qui la menacent à zoug a heureusement
enfin voila c'est quand même assez
curieux mais c'est c'est le sait c'est
un va enfin c'est un vrai problème à
aider les pauvres gens de charlie hebdo
l'ont vécue si le draw blasphème qui est
comme inscrit dans notre dans notre
histoire dans notre culture
oui devient aujourd'hui problématique
d'autant que là on est même 80 places
fermées hier ces problématiques charlier
non non jamais mais on avait le goût
roth critique des religions il est il
est inabordable français contre un sur
beaucoup de médias il est totale en tout
cas pour certaines religieux parce que
sur france inter on dit que jésus et pd1
10 des chansons mais voilà il ya une
chanson et puis avait avec les
humoristes sont autour il a oui oui
c'est vrai il est sexuel non mais c'est
très bien se faire à fond mais je pense
à stéphane guillon qui continuaient dans
un spectacle disait moi je comprendrai
kalergi aux catholiques ce que je suis
pas fou c'est une façon de dire qu'en
effet il ya une inégalité
c'est parmi eux alors là l'a7 peaufine
n'a pas placé vis bien évidemment elle a
absolument à un disney répondu une
attaque d'un type qui la traitent de
sales équivalent à venir les
gorges et enfin peut on comprendre vous
déconnez dans le même enfin pas dans le
même la même chose mais quand même ce
déferlement de haine c'est quand même
elle
on est quand même dans une société un
peu inquiétante non vous ne trouvez pas
c'est pas une société mais c'est juste
si c'est quand même nom mais en
attendant un nouveau point de vue naître
période c'est un modèle que certains
cherchent imposé mais sympa la société
dans laquelle je vis et de jean-charles
vous disiez elle n'a pas blasphémer mais
la question se pose pas n'importe
elle a eu des propos insultant vis-à-vis
de la religion vis-à-vis de l'islam
c'est son droit le plus strict critiqué
de manière argumentée mais aussi insulté
et c'est bon jusqu'à présent tout cela
ne tombe pas sous le coup d'une loi
particulière cela tombe bien c'est très
intéressant puisque ici une plainte de
voir quel sera son sort
jean baptiste tout a été dit et on peut
effectivement regretter l'outrance et
rappeler la liberté d'expression je
trouve qu'effectivement ce phénomène est
tout à fait symptomatique de l'hystérie
de notre pays en ce moment sur la
question des religions et notamment de
l'islam
ceci étant évidemment comme amplifiés
par par la médiatisation ont évoqué tout
à l'heure mais aussi des réseaux sociaux
jouent toujours terriblement que je
crois que c'est assez regrettable assez
triste est que sam ça confine avec une
sorte aussi de deux pseudos mollard
moralisation à l'extrême qui est
extrêmement inquiétante et qui peut
rappeler certaines dérives même si
évidemment on en est très loin mais qui
je trouve extrêmement inquiétante merci
merci à tous a alors changé vous les
idées avec marianne ostrom et lui
changer vous les idées si vous voulez
voir il ya notre amie florence mercadier
qui fait qu'ils participent une
exposition peinture c'est un
saint-hilarion ces deux le 1er et 2
février je crois voilà c'est sa première
expo alors comme tout le monde connaît
pas saint-hilarion c'est pas très loin
de rambouillet oui indications salle des
fêtes yves robert a beau et oui y'a pas
mieux qu yves robert dagnan défendre et
la guerre des deux n'a gardé formidable
possible voilà merci merci jean baptiste
guittet remercie stéphane minson
remercie jean charles lajoie ni à très
vite pour un nouveau pas
[Musique]